we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p there is a
caller who calls in frequently his name
his real name as far as I know is troy
York but he calls in with all sorts of
different characters he has one called
Jamal Jenkins who's a black college
student he has one called Ramon Ramon
Susana guy he has a all these different
characters here he is just as Troy York
attacking me for even thinking about
interviewing Jen cougar and of course
attacking Jen Cougars physical
appearance which is the height of debate
right when you when you can't wait on
substance just attack the way somebody
looks yeah why did you have that big fat
idiot scenic ogre on your show the man
is an idiot he's a stupid it makes the
left look so stupid and you'd only
realize it what what's gonna be next
you're gonna have Michael Moore on your
show we're talking with the Detroit
Tigers hands and you'll be you'll be
interviewing him and what why do you
always have dr. giant garden Ron all
he's talking about Trump psychological
problems when in fact it is the far left
in crazy academia and crazies
alternative news outlet media like
yourself who really had psychological
problems concerning president Trump yeah
Wow absolutely devastating and of course
you will notice that no substantive
arguments made there by Troy York about
Jan Cougar merely saying that Genki
augurs weight is something that he finds
relevant and basically leaving it there
these are the types of folks were
fighting okay so and I say that not so
that you figure out how to go and argue
with them I say that so that you don't
waste your breath let's focus on get out
the vote why would we debate with that
person and say hey you should really
change your vote they're gone they're
gone let's find people that already
agree with us and get them to go out and
vote we have a great bonus show today we
are going to talk about the Boy Scouts
are really struggling and Mormons who
typically love the Boy Scouts Mormons
are pulling four hundred thousand kids
out of the Boy Scouts and this is going
to be even worse for the Boy Scouts we
will also talk about the very
rich pharmaceutical family the Sackler
z' they are withdrawing nearly 11
billion dollars from purdue
pharmaceuticals they withdrew nearly
eleven billion dollars from Purdue as
the opioid crisis mounted we will also
talk about the latest on impeachment
some of the sidebar stories and
procedural kind of funny things that
have been going on all of that and so
much more on today's bonus show how do
you access the bonus show it's very easy
you become a member at join pakman.com
or you become a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show both take under
a minute and get you instant access to
the bonus show if you want to be a
member but you're waiting for the
perfect time let me suggest that January
1st is the perfect time on January 1st
we will be sending out an email to
everybody on our newsletter with a
disgusting I mean it's just a sickening
obscene membership special where you
will be able to lock in a membership for
all of 2020 at a hugely discounted rate
if that sounds interesting sign up for
our newsletter at david pakman.com upper
right at the top of the right-hand
column type in your email address
January 1 you will get a very special
email from me with a one-time use code
otherwise I would rather talk to you on
the bonus show today because it is going
to be such a good one